coaches can only say so much players really have
to air it out and say we need more from everybody
and it starts with me whether it's the top player
like Jack Hughes or whoever it may be if you were
tuning in expecting to see Damon serson return to
New Jersey he is injured and out for the next 6
weeks that lays a big hit on like be Behind the B
having ball shot is save this season for sure but
wants to continue to work on that consistency on
a nightly basis L snaps off the face off and it's
a blocker save for rir Schmidt is fourth over
the opening 5 minutes shots now 4-1 make it 51
Columbus as Veronica is stoned by Schmid Kevin
Ball settles R shot fluttering toward the front
with Brendan Smith providing a screen never made
it through as Brun Jenner chips it out marenko
in Ball battle marenko gets to it cuts to the
front pman makes a pass save what a great save
and protecting the pck watch right here as you see
that puck bouncing tough one for ball to handle he
tries to stay with it and then he took a swipe at
it missed but you see marchenko really use that
body to Shield the puck in a big save right off
the Bater has practiced since Monday Tierney to
the outside Jer brat shoots kick save M Le that
was a flutter and it bounced off a blue jacket
along the way now L attacks Hughes and Luke H uses
the skate to take it away line WIS it back to the
front til It Wide Jake Bean walks the line lies
it for Eric good Branson the defenseman from down
low puts it on Save Schmid ball keeps the puck on
a string works it wide to Jack Hughes trying to
change directions Jasper brat takes it high slot
here's toley Off the Bench his shots blocked he
gets it again down low off the side that it didn't
go for br the ice that's the effort you want Bry
was talking about comes away with it here's Jack
Hughes with all kinds of space he stops he shoots
Le makes the save Hamilton throws one on and
bean blocks that as well R across Hughes finds
it probes to FY looking to get it across a sliding
play by Bean Hughes takes it again Off the Wall he
comes in across for brat that's broken up strong
stick work by Johnny Gad this line is just buzzing
Hughes trying to funnel It Forward Jenner broke it
up and Columbus finally can clear it as gdo sends
it out Jenner comes forward drops it for gdo he's
down deep G drill centers in front and boom Jenner
scores now this is the way it has gone couple
of goals leads this the other night and their
Victory against the Blackhawks leads their team
in that category he's all alone on the doorstep
and Johnny gdo finds him and the coverage has
to be better you see missed assignments there
and Jenner slammed D might not look pretty but
that's an athletic play when you can go down like
that and still control it poot skates through
a check from Olivier who loses his stick along
the way now poot almost knocks it away from
Bean poot bangs it free Alexander hul shoots
he scor Andre poot knocks it loose and Holtz
ties the game million doll replay brought to
you by the New Jersey Lottery remember anything
can happen in Jersey and there's the work for
Block I'm talking about as he strips that P from
being the defenseman for Columbus it started with
a physical play and for che as he took the body
and holds picks up that loose Puck and snaps it
that nice little escapability from now he's under
pressure again L pressuring takes it away down L
tries to slam it in and Aira Schmid makes the
sa Smith comes hard knocks as far as the Blue
Line Jer brat trying to read the passing Lane
marchenko going in the slot throws it on and
shid makes the save Hamilton Takes It Centers it
skipped away from Jer Bratt Eric good branton's
on it 42 seconds to go in the first period it's a
break out to Eric Robinson behind the defense he
scores pressure and perfect pass out of the
Columbus Zone they hate to see that happen
late in the period shot as he picks it up off
his skate on the pass right here Robinson the
Jersey native what a shot he was a high school
teammate of Johnny grro he's playing with him
now at the NHL level and he has his first goal
of the Season as he leaked out there taking a
risk leaking out like that but it and all of
a sudden alus takes it away H behind that Dean
here's a one time blast and Sean thers Stoned by
m leans it's not like these guys want to do it but
if one guy does it two guys do it collectively
you're not going to have any good good results
here you have to think every player we don't
have the puck where am I where's the dangerous
part to from the slers Le makes a save there's a
good save there but take the dangerous area away
work from the inside out we just don't see enough
hockey smarts as far as that coverage bill so far
lenky flutters it on it's covered up here by
Kira Schmid and Colin Miller gets engaged with
Matthew Olivier big be Bastion makes a crunching
hit Devils have the puff Marino rips it through
traffic bouncing in front and M lein covers
I mean that's what you're going to want this
group of three to do up front bang their bodies
around and try and score a dir goals Colson Hall
line has been the devil's most consistent tonight
shift after shift little miscommunication between
Hamilton and seen ther that free up cyinder and
Akira schmidtz there to make the save missing
pieces but at this point you got to figure out
how to win with with the guys he got Healy on
the ice at the moment as brats into the offensive
end sets up Hugh backand kicked away M leak has
made some strong see the last handful of shifts
to try to get the equalizer there's the shot
from Hughes gets it off quickly on the back hand
and you see M leens kick it out and watch just
goes Rats on the loose PT ball comes down low
ball cutting in front Kon on his stack and
forces M lein to make a tough save how about
Kevin Ball there keeps it on his stick still
a minute left on the power play still circling
he shoots M spills the rebound and still free
and doesn't go good positioning right off the
shoulder maybe brat wanted to get it a little
higher but they're working Jack's got it once
more little stilling in front it comes back to
Luke and he knocks it along but it's blocked
Away by Columbus but haven't been able to get
any of past Elvis M leans Columbus still leads
two one he got to keep on coming here's a chance
for Mercer turned away as he would like but he
would like to see Dosa Mercer Corral that and
somehow bang at home Puck goes on edge right
here Le is right there couldn't quite control
this rebound it was more of a knuckle Puck you
see her just went on edge and he couldn't get
all of it he's made 27 from both sides Shing for
it it rolls to defley his shot bounc off a couple
of bodies now grro is behind the devil's D he's in
he shoots and a car there keeping the Devil Within
one
devs get caught throw Hughes coming right back
the other way spins waiting for his changing
teammates down Broadway sh brings it off the
post Jack's got it again a seen pass across
for Luke Hughes Hamilton wants it he settles
it down R it to Jack Hughes Jack down low to
Foley side door save M Le L he's down for
bremmer leinn stops that one as well with
47.6 to go he's just very calm in the net and
making every save that he that he has to that
one you thought maybe would Bank off Jack Hugh
taken down along the boards Columbus clears 41
Shots on goal just one finds the back of the net
and the Devils lose for the seventh time in nine